josée legault martin biron sébastien
bovet bonsoir il faut boire je pense
qu'ils aient pu entendre de madame
groulx de l'ordre des psychologues du
québec qui dit dans le fond l épaule il
l'a pas dit comme ça mais d'enfants a
dit on suppose au pis le vrai plan qu'on
atteint parce que évidemment ils disent
payer nous pour valeo public on va aller
voir déjà puis on va libérer les les
dates en font autant si vous le voulez
bien
en chambre l'opposition puis monsieur
karma qui répond sur ce plan qui selon
l'opposition n'est vraiment pas assez
robuste pour faire face aux problèmes
psychologiques de santé mentale de
beaucoup de gens dans la population
le ministre a affirmé ce matin qu'il n'y
avait pas de crise en santé mentale
c'est complètement déconnecté de la
réalité d'équipé quoi ce président il
doit faire mieux que son annonce de ce
matin actuellement malgré l'augmentation
de la demande les listes d'attentes
baisse on est passé de 28 mille
personnes en attente
quand on a commencé à vérifier et on est
rendu à 16000 donc les services sont
disponibles
il faut passer par les bonnes étapes
le système a été étranglée dans les 15
dernières années
les ressources ont quitté le bateau on
se contente de mettre en place des
lignes téléphoniques pour nous c'est pas
suffisant alors le gouvernement à annie
les besoins jusque hier
maintenant il veut passer à l'action
c'est tard bon il ya le 25 millions qui
est annoncée aujourd'hui pour les jeunes
mais aussi on parle d'un plan plus
global
martin biron attendu en tout cas lors
des pics colada la taz
ils ont demandé à monsieur qu'armand des
fonds ça se résume à ça finalement
simple un public universel de
services psychologiques les libéraux
avaient fait cette suggestion là à la
période de questions environ 2 3
semaines et le premier ministre s'était
montée ou montré ouvert ce type de
service à ce type de plein les libéraux
avaient évalué ce à 300 millions de
dollars monsieur legault avait dit ça va
coûter plus cher que ça il faudra voir
comment le faire alors oui c'est
peut-être une bonne idée mais ça ne se
fera pas en criant ciseau où on va
travailler ce nouveau programme là si on
le fait entre temps il faut donner un
coup de main parce que on commence la
voir leurs sacs de cette pandémie après
ses sept huit mois rappelez-vous le
verglas sa durer entre une et trois
semaines et là est la question d'être
détresse des gens qui avaient été
touchés par cette crise là avait été
très importante et ça avait fait les
manchettes ç'avait été extrêmement
douloureux pour certaines familles là on
est dans une pandémie qui valorise durer
au-delà d'un an
il va falloir trouver des ressources
parce que les chiffres sont alarmants
quand on dit que la tante baisse et
qu'on a on a quand même 16 mille
personnes qui attendent c'est quand même
énorme
essayez d'avoir rendez vous pour votre
genou pour vous dans ses rues ce chsct
s'est laissé pardon si je sais je dis ça
c'est une autre histoire mais même en
cabinet privé pas de même en cabinet
privé il peut avoir de la tente où
effectivement vous avez raison vous avez
raison mais ceux qui ont les moyens
c'est un peu plus facile d'habitude un
peu plus rapide dans certaines plus d'un
système public c'est très très très long
avant de s'asseoir devant une ou un
psychologue
josé beaucoup de gens disent ils et il
est un qui a un plan robuste pour faire
face à cette détresse relayé minuit et
cinq ans et c'est très très clair et
comme pour tout le reste dans la
pandémie braque les projecteurs sur les
flics les faiblesses de notre système je
m'excuse de me répéter là dessus mais en
santé mentale
même avant la pandémie c'était comme ça
une majorité de psychologues sont au
privé parce qu'ils sont mieux payés
parce qu'ils sont plus libres parce
qu'ils ont de meilleures conditions et
une minorité reste au public hall pour
les raisons contraires
alors déjà c'était difficile très
franchement pour avoir du soutien
psychologique sérieux la même avant la
pandémie pas les payer fallait aller au
privé
et c'est encore la même chose là on est
dans cette situation exceptionnelle qui
est ce qui est décevant de la part du
gouvernement
c'est que bon ce qui était annoncé
aujourd'hui c'est bien pour les jeunes
mais la détresse psychologique à la peau
de génération ne parle pas du mien c'est
à travers tous les âges que ça joue et
c'est une situation temporaire donc ce
serait pas un déboursé récurrents ce
serait un divorce étant port à élever
oui mais comme le disait la docteure
groupe ça me coûtait combier de ne pas
se voir les deux ça et je me demande je
me demande si c'est pas parce que la
détresse psychologique c'est invisible
lorsque les gouvernements précédents ont
eu des pénuries au public pour des
chirurgies
ils ont déboursé pour acheter des plages
dans des cliniques chirurgicales du
privé mais contente de parler de ça j'en
ai un très bon exemple c'est un peu ce
que propose l'ordre cht nous voilà
comment acheter des blocs opératoires
dans le prime à la clinique privée voilà
jeté nous développe
puis nous on va en voir du monde on va
accélérer parce qu'en sic nos membres
vont aller au public
d'un seul coup là il n'y a pas de
service donc et sauf que ces essais
c'est un problème de fond c'est un
problème social c'est que la détresse
psychologique ça ne se voit pas comme un
genou déboîté ou un dos des fai ou année
des rats mais ça fait au tas de dommages
oui pirates avons aujourd'hui sébastien
la dr times dans un rapport à il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup d'indicateurs qui
étaient au rouge la alcoolisme usage de
drogues dépression auxilia la rue galos
conjugales
alors bien sûr que quand on accumule
tous à sébastien il ya comme une urgence
est ce qu'elle est bien ressenti à ce
que je parlais en groupe gt amp étonné
de voir ben j'ai pas rédigés par la
monsieur karma mais une attente depuis
le début de la crise je me suis en effet
d'entre-vous mois de mars avec elle pas
nous
nous on veut un plat pour subventionner
des visites chez les psychologues il
l'avait vu venir probablement la vague
aussi de détresse psychologique c'est
comme si en santé il y avait deux
approches la proche qui concerne tout ce
qui est en dessous des épaules
il approche qui concerne poussière au
dessus des épaules et pourtant c'est
tout aussi important
josé diz est bien quand on a une
fracture ouverte ça paraît beaucoup plus
que quand on est en détresse
psychologique 300 millions de dollars
pour la proposition des libéraux
c'est beaucoup d'argent certainement
mais disons qu'on n'a pas trop de
difficulté à signer des chèques pour des
hôpitaux puis pour des des chirurgies et
ainsi de suite d'un réseau de la santé
c'est une somme qui pourrait
correspondre donc un effort qu'on
devrait faire pour éliminer ou atténuer
les listes d'attentes me suis clairement
a beau dire il ya seize mille personnes
sur la liste d'attenté ça diminue ça
reste quand même inacceptable dans une
société comme le québec qui est autant
gens qui soient en attente pour des
services de base comme celui jaune trop
là où son clip et pour publier que des
fois lorsqu'une listes d'attentes pèse
pour des services comme ça c'est parce
que déjà qu'ils se découragent c'est ça
ce que je sais c'est exactement qu'il
existe très bien monsieur macron je vous
parle monsieur m'a cran parce que là on
voit quand on est vraiment parti pour
une longue longue longue période
en europe on re confirme de façon
extrêmement sérieuse
ce qui contribue à un découragement
aussi le tout est dans tout et monsieur
lacroix a répondu très clairement je
trouve à ceux qui disaient pourquoi on
laisse pas aller le virus dans le fond
on a perdu le contrôle de son le alliés
les gens vont utiliser la fameuse et
multi collective va jouer ils disent on
pourra faire ça mais il ya un coût à
seuil un coût humain
je vous propose donc un petit extrait de
cet appel à la nation qu'il a fait il ya
quelques minutes en france nous sommes
tous en europe
surpris par l'évolution du virus débordé
par une deuxième vague qui nous le
savons désormais sera sans doute plus
dur et plus meurtrière que la première
nous pourrions certains préconisent ne
rien faire et assumée de laisser le
virus circule et le conseil scientifique
à évaluer les conséquences d'une telle
option elles sont implacables à très
court terme cela signifie le tri entre
les patients à l'hôpital et d'essayer
quelques mois c'est au moins quatre cent
mille morts supplémentaires à déplorer
il ay quand il maintient nous on a
choisi de préserver le maximum de vies
humaines c'est nos valeurs et c'est
alors sébastien c'est clair il y avait
beaucoup de chiffres d'ailleurs dans ce
point de presse la des tableaux etc
on se dit j'espère que ça n'arrivera pas
ici cette cette ampleur de deuxième
vague parce que il est totalement
débordé le dit lui même et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il va serrer la vis
un peu plus vendredi les l'histoire du
couvre-feu de toute évidence pas
fonctionné en france on doit aller une
étape plus loin vous rappelez vous ici
au québec on s'était dit est ce qu'on
devrait appliquer un couvre-feu laisser
les restaurants et les bars ouverts
l'exemple français est l'exemple à ne
pas suivre en tout cas avec le peu de
recul qu'on a en ce moment donc monsieur
si on ramène la situation ici françois
le groupe et on en parlait hier soir ou
au moins se compare beaucoup à la france
doute pas la meilleure comparaison parce
que la france est en progression
expérience exponentielle de son nombre
de cas mais disons que l'exemple de la
france doit servir dans les choses
peut-être à ne pas faire à court moyen
terme parce qu'ils en sont rendus à
avoir des mesures beaucoup plus
contraignante que ce qu'on a ici
oui puis l'acceptabilité là bas
n'est pas évident il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui déjà à marseille on
l'a vu dès le début à paris acquis qui
ne sont qui sont furieux de tout ça donc
ça sera surveillé marc tiennent aussi la
légion là la fameuse adhésion on est en
face parce que j'allais justement dire
s'il n'y avait pas tellement choix de
formules chocs le président macron parce
que quand les restaurants ont été
fermées dans le sud il ya pas mal plus
de récalcitrants en france tu peux y en
avoir ici alors il devait comme le
gouvernement legault convaincre les gens
d'embarquer dans son bateau et de suivre
il peut pas se payer des manifestations
partout en france et envoyer la police
mater les gens sur le terrain
au québec c'est la même chose c'est le
lien de confiance monsieur legault doit
convaincre faire peur à ses peurs aux
gens pour qu'ils suivent les consignes
et qu'il travaille avec le gouvernement
est clairement tant au québec qu'en
france est bien dans bien d'autres pays
d'ailleurs d'europe
on ne veut pas
et d'immunité collective justement parce
qu'il a parlé c'est passionnant parlé
hier vous avez raison a dit dizaines de
fois monsieur legault a parlé de la
france hier joseph ça peut l'aider là on
va regarder là bas est ce que vous
voulez qu'on sera à des bons si on fait
l'équivalence 50 mais le cas en france
et comme ça mais le cas quotidien ici
c'est énorme et rapidement notre système
de santé serait on pas débordé mais
submergé complètement à jouer ça peut
l'aider d'une certaine façon
monsieur legault avant ce qu'il a à
vendre aux québécois no way petit à
court terme mais prions que your pas une
résurgence encore plus importante ici
parce qu'il y en a déjà une allée fait
un bond donc oui peut-être mais c'est ça
reste loin la france pour beaucoup de
monde et je pense que le lier ce jour le
lien confiance se joue entre chaque
gouvernement et sa population
indépendamment de ce qui se passe
ailleurs j'ai terrible à dire mais voilà
non mais ça c'est la réalité
ça m'a surprise par exemple que monsieur
legault ou son point de presse en disant
regardez ce qui se passe en france
ils ont aussi fermé les restaurants et
aux autres aussi faire tout est fermé
barre tout à faire des folies j'adore ça
s'enflamme l'école un peu partout le
lendemain bombay j'osais vous dit ce qui
est important de voir si la relation que
les gouvernants et leurs populations
dans chacun chacune des provinces ici au
québec qu'ailleurs
là le gouvernement legault était pas
content fait la leçon à l'opposition
aujourd'hui on va vous découragez vous
miner le moral des québécois on va
écouter ce qui lui a fait dire ça
d'abord madame anglade hier après sa
cervelle madame guilbaud et re
commentaires de l'opposition ensuite la
confiance des québécois
si rod un peu plus chaque jour la
conséquence de ça c'est que certains
maintenant temps demain vers vers une
désobéissance civile alors il faut à
tout prix que le premier ministre se
ressaisissent par rapport à la crise de
la coved 19
il en va maintenant de la paix sociale
au québec
oui on peut critiquer le gouvernement
mais à un moment donné le il faut être
responsable puis faut tous travailler
dans le même sens vers le même objectif
est miné le moral des québécois et
minimiser les efforts des québécois de
la manière dont ça a été fait hier entre
autres par le parti libéral je considère
que ce n'est pas responsable à l'ange à
leur lance un appel aujourd'hui au parti
d'opposition
soyez solidaires soyez constructif
le premier ministre nous a dit que ça
allait bien aller ils avaient un plan
qui n'a pas fonctionné
il ya eu un deuxième plan de 28 jours
qui n'a pas fonctionné et la
vice-première ministre ici nous dit
encore que ça continue à bien aller
peut-être que ce qu'elle aimerait la
vice première ministre et que tout le
monde rentre docilement à la maison fait
c'est ça qu'elle souhaite mais nous on
souhaite avoir des réponses de la part
du gouvernement
le gouvernement de la cac devrait
arrêter de pointer tout le monde du
doigt il devrait prendre ses
responsabilités et se demander ce que
eux ils peuvent faire pour mieux
communiquer pour faire preuve de plus de
transparence de plus de cohérence dans
leurs conseils le défi de 28 alors
désolé me chercher nos l'on va vous
reprendre une autre heure alors
l'opposition qui pose des questions
c'est quand même normal
sébastien beauvais mais on ça que le
gouvernement était extrêmement hérité
bon par les critiques d'une part mais
par le commentaire de madame anglade
hier oui et monsieur legault il était
aussi à la période des questions hier
ils n'étaient pas la vie en est question
aujourd'hui dire le mot désobéissance
civile ou dire que la paix sociale est
effritée ou et qui est un danger pour la
paix sociale
ça veut pas dire appelé à la
désobéissance civile savait pas dire
dire qu'il ya plus de paix sociale dans
le contexte dans lequel dominique
anglade a dit elle n'a jamais appelé à
la désobéissance civile heures la mèche
et cours au gouvernement c'est ce qu'on
constate depuis deux jours
madame guilbeault qui fait la leçon la
morale ou partie de position aujourd'hui
c'est la même madame guide book i
vendredi appelé la population de québec
à se ressaisir
elle même laissé entendre que il y avait
un relâchement par la désobéissance
civile mais un relâchement dans les
mesures les consignes sanitaires elle
même appelé donc la population à adhérer
au conseil général du gouvernement
aujourd'hui à 10 ans quand elle et j'en
suis très bien aujourd'hui google nous
dit que tout le monde sait très bien
qu'il ya un sondage qui nous dicte le
monde suit très bien aussi alors c'est
normal que les gens soient un peu perdu
mais jamais les partis d'opposition
n'ont été à la désobéissance civile
quand on quand on parle de l'application
aussi
une application téléphonique là le
gouvernement aussi la tergiversé pendant
des longues semaines avant de l'adopter
cette application est l'un des partis
d'opposition ont critiqué mais c'est le
rôle de l'opposition
ouais jozic j'ai exactement alors
qu'elles ont dit oui on ne sommes pas
dans un gouvernement d'union nationale
ça crie là il ya encore des partis
politiques le bon mais je pense que les
changes entre madame anglade et madame
gbagbo c'est un échange purement
partisane de part et d'autre madame
anglade
elle a beaucoup généralisée aussi elle a
parlé de la confiance des québécois qui
s'érode partie des québécois et la
désobéissance civile ben c'était
quelqu'un propriétaire de jim qui ont
changé d'idée du moment où le
gouvernement a dit justement il y aura
des amendes et puis c'est tout parce que
ce soit pas légal il va y avoir un
décret et les gens ont suivi lisons haut
ils ont ils ont accepté ça même les
propriétaires de jim donc de parler de
deux possibilités de bris de paix
sociale est nettement exagéré en même
temps madame guilbaud c'est très exagéré
ou s'il de demander aux partis
d'opposition la de rentrer dans le rang
et puis de dire la même chose que le
gouvernement écoute et on n'est plus
dans la première vague ça on est plutôt
confiné et puis il ya des choses qui ne
se passe pas bien et c'est normal que
l'opposition pose des questions et là
dessus je pense que gabriel nadeau
dubois était peut-être que plus âgés le
plus habile en suivant les deux vrais
problèmes c'est à dire les questions que
de plus en plus de gens se reposent sur
des problèmes de communication parrain
de transparence problème de cohérence
dans les mesures sanitaires et ça ça
fait partie du boulot de l'opposition
martine de rendre plus clairs les
critères que qu'on met sur la table
quand on discute dans ce fameux comité
de crise le matin avec dr house heures
jeux pour aminé c'est qu'on a qu'on en
sache un peu plus sur ce qui motive les
décisions de ces essais je deviens avait
un peu pour tout le monde on institue le
gouvernement cette mission là il veut
aplatir sa courbe il ya besoin de
l'appui
mais les partis d'opposition pose des
questions qui sont légitimes
effectivement sur la séparation entre le
politique et la santé publique
mais la sortie d'aujourd'hui elles
étaient planifiés en ce que ce que la
vice-première ministre voulait faire
c'est faire une sortie publique monsieur
legault aurait pu faire une réunion avec
les trois chefs ils ont décidé de faire
une sortie publique pour que ça se
retrouve sur dans les médias sociaux et
que ça chauffe un peu alors que ça se
retrouve sur les panels ça c'est réussi
voilà merci à vous trois au revoir à
bille très bien merci
l'histoire